we've got two lines here that intersect
or cross and we want to find out what
happens with the composition a
composition means like two or more
transformations so what we're going to
do is we reflect this preimage over this
line of reflection over line L okay and
if we do that it's going to look
something like that now when you do a
reflection you want to make sure you're
measuring the perpendicular distance
okay and you're going the same distance
on the other side of the line of
reflection so it's just like folding it
over that line so now what you can see
is that this is going to be looking
something like this we'll call this
figure a prime okay or the new one now
we're going over line m so we're going
to take this image we're going to
reflect it over line out and so again
same idea
we're gonna fold it over this line now
the figure looks like something like
this and we'll call this one a double
Prime so what happened is we reflected
then we reflected again but what this
ended up resulting in is a rotation so
actually like a turn you can see you're
pivoting about this point right here and
you're turning this and you can see that
it's going to be if let's say this is a
ninety degree angle you can see is
actually rotating 180 degrees so it
doesn't have to be two perpendicular
lines the angle here can be anything
that you want it to be if it's 60
degrees the rotation will be 120 it'll
always be twice the angle that's in
between the two intersecting lines so
that's basically how you do this it's a
reflection followed by another
reflection it ends up in a rotation
double the angle between the two
intersecting lines so I hope this helped
you understand this constant a little
bit better
subscribe to the channel check out some
of my other videos on Mario's math
tutoring YouTube channel and I look
forward to helping in the future videos